so hope everybody's day is better than
mine let's just go wit back oh I'm gonna
blame the full moon and leave it at that
that'll do a start I'm high not great
I am tired and worn out and fed up and
just all stuff that isn't fun to talk
about so we'll try and find more
pleasant topics Oh morning from
Australia oh say hi to Krispy pro for me
I assume you all know each other that's
the way it works in Australia right uh
what's today's water good sir today's
water is Riesling do you want puns to
make you feel better I'm sorry that
sentence doesn't actually make sense
puns to make someone feel better oh dear
what a terrifying concept just chilling
with a joker in Totoro yeah and Hedwig
and Fozzie Bear and who else kisi from
there no face and Wonder Woman I swear I
haven't been drinking prior to this
starting what's your personal treatment
for an ear infection going to the
hospital
which I know under the circumstances
isn't isn't actually the best option so
I don't know I actually have never
actually had an ear infection formerly I
scraped my eardrum once and that was bad
like that that that hurt and I went to
the hospital for that um mind if I use
this stream to seek refuge from a Star
Wars comment section oh dear god yes
please come seek shelter be safe my god
but that way madness lies why would you
do that cheers from Kosovo hey there
how's quarantine treating you it's
driving me absolutely up the wall could
you rank your least favorite episodes of
Doctor Who the thing is once I'm further
there's a couple of episodes specific
ones that I need to re-watch but once
I'm a little bit further into my revisit
of earlier stuff I am gonna have to redo
my 10 worst episodes of Doctor Who list
but there's some things that I need to
watch again with fresh eyes to determine
whether or not they either would be on
there or would stay on there versus the
last time I did it which was a long time
ago how are you spending warranty no I'm
doing a lot of drying and my hay fever
is going wild I'm working the like
here's the thing Mike I'm able to do my
job from home which on the one hand is
good because you know I'm having no
interruption to my income but on the
other hand you know I see people
offering advice you know Oh things to do
with the extra time you have which I
don't because I still have a I still
have an eight-hour workday five days a
week so I don't actually have any more
time during quarantine I'm just working
in the same place I I just don't drive
home at the end of the day because I'm
already here that's
seriously the only difference for me
right now
have you ever watches asteroid was this
Eagleton Jumanji before welcome to the
jungle I did I remember thinking that it
was fine and kind of leaving it at that
what is the Star Wars comment section a
place not to be trodden hey just got
here hey there Ben
is that an asexual flag hoodie um I
don't think might be I don't know the
asexual flag colors so if it is
unintentionally tell me I'm not the only
one spending the quarantine
impersonating the stereotypes of a
Hufflepuff food and drink obsessed no
you are probably not alone on that my
friends forcing me to watch shadow
hunters so in term I'm making her watch
Merlyn well you know that is that is
only fair I am currently working my way
through American Gods which I'm not
gonna talk about too much because that's
guy that's gonna get a review custard
creams are jammie Dodgers I know
decisive um I don't know either one
particularly well I've had jammie
Dodgers I think once and from what folks
told me they were like the not even the
good ones so I I can't tell you what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna open up some
fortune cookies because someone was nice
enough to PayPal me money to get Chinese
food which was immensely appreciated
thank you very much it did help a little
I wish I could say my day improved it
really didn't but they do our Star Wars
the Clone Wars series I have not
now ah over Chua lug Thank You Tracy
you know just listen me crunch on this
[Laughter]
my fortune says great you're ready for a
party whoo Cheers
since you have your address in the
description have you ever had a fan show
up for your house well no because that's
a p.o box I don't live at the post
office so no that has not happened and
he's in the sixth doctor episode time
lash if so I'm sorry haha no I haven't
seen that one yet
ace is black gray white and purple so no
because I've got navy gray and purple is
what I've got
if I'm not mistaken I believe that I'm a
Ravenclaw very cool Connor tried
watching Tiger Kings for 10 minutes
thought it was stupid I've had a lot of
people tell me I should watch it it's
the kind of thing that if I'm gonna
watch it I need to watch it with someone
else who I can riff on it with it's not
the thing I it's not the kind of thing I
can just sit in my house and watch on my
own because like honestly and I say this
legitimately I used to watch and enjoyed
stuff like Jersey Shore and Flavor of
Love but the reason I enjoyed those
things is because I watch them with
someone who I could grip on them with
and we drank while we watched I'm on my
own right now so Tiger King holds very
little appeal
I wonder if this quarantine is how the
third doctor felt on Earth can't be a
million miles off
beware fortune don't want repeat of
Freaky Friday ha ha ha
it's disgusting how and the bells of st.
John the doctor puts the already cook
heat back on the plate I actually forgot
about that and I rewatched that one
recently Thank You Charleston weird
question presuming they wouldn't try and
kill you witch doctor or the witch
doctor who monster or alien would you
most like to date alright on the promise
that she couldn't kill me or leave me in
a situation where I would die
I'd go with Missy uh well we got this
time in human endeavor chance favors the
prepared mind no no is this preparation
I'm gonna say that it is so thank you
for that chosen Oh Thank You Tracy is
this stream a party the stream is always
a party yeah yes it is uh I can't
believe Joe xotic ran for president see
that's the funny thing
I knew the name Joe exotic way before
Tiger King was a thing because I
remember a clip of him trying to run for
president that John Oliver used like I
guess it'd be about four years ago now
during the 2016 election fish finger
doesn't and custard or custard and fish
fingers ooh oh so tricky to pass the
quarantine me and my mum are doing a
massive rewatch of new who just finished
day of the moon made me think about
watching everything from rivers view
it's quite tragic I keep meaning to sit
down and and I know other people have
done it but I don't want to look it up I
want to figure it out for myself what
the chronological order of River Song
episodes would be like from her point of
view some of it unfortunately gets a
little bit twisted because there are
some episodes in which
she appears as a younger and then older
version of herself
something like day the moon because
River Song older is in it but then we
know by the end this little girl we see
is so you have to judge where you put
someone like that but it's one of those
things that I meant to do was figure out
a chronological watching order for River
Song episodes do you think it would be a
good idea if Joe Martin played the
fourteenth doctor and a Tom Baker the
old favorite style thing I'm not sure
what you mean by Tom be your old
favorite style I actually had this one I
do think she should just play the
fourteenth doctor I think that would be
very cool I remember when I took the
Pottermore quiz house quiz I chose all
the Slytherin things see I didn't not on
purpose anyway but I ended up there so
apparently I just leaned that way what's
your favorite author um that ooh hmm
favorite author
probably still Douglas Adams Neil Gaiman
ZUP there though - what's the black
thing on your back um I see what you did
there uh remember the Mandarin hated
fortune cookies uh-huh I would take su
tech I have a thing for evil voices that
is a good voice although that if you
like that boys that means you could also
go with the Beast you got options
whoo Doubleday also greetings from my
old man cat Rowland as he is being
exceptionally lovely just now I imagine
that most people's cats either think the
quarantine is the best thing ever or the
worst thing ever
depending on the nature of the pet and
how much they actually like being around
their people I'm sure dogs are thrilled
I bet you some cats are pissed
who is the filthiest dr. virtue of virus
wise I don't know probably the second
doctor maybe the fourth No
be the fourth because he's he's you know
sticking his hand in the and the jelly
baby is offering them to other people
oh yeah oh yeah he's easy carrier Thank
You randomness
I'll quarantine and no play makes makes
Lewis a dull boy yeah sounds about right
amra playing Mario the thousand-year
door you can hardly wait for your review
of the cheesiness yes so I don't usually
announce ahead of time things that I've
been commissioned to review except Jolie
actually brought it up that I've now
been commissioned to review the video
game Paper Mario thousand-year door
which I've never played before I've
gotten a copy which was a little
trickier than I expected to be but I did
manage to get one and I'll hopefully
I'll get to that soon I've got a number
of other Commission things I need to get
through first my cousin my cousin has
had her baby her name is Kaylie oh
that's sweet one of those his co-workers
had a baby what lipstick color is it
that you're wearing it's a stunning
color on you this shade is called my
natural lip color I this this is that's
just me I'm behind on questions um no
one knows what order rivers timeline is
actually in we just hope the current one
is correct saw story dog sprained its
tail from wagging I think I heard that
is it sad that my life is the equivalent
of the lyrics of City on fire from
Sweeney Todd oh yeah mr. mr. dogs
haven't had this much watch since
Pokemon dropped that is that's probably
true my five cats won't leave me be now
that'll keep you busy
sad that my life is the Akula no no I
read that yeah okay this is probably the
dumbest question ever
probably not but we'll see but in series
12 episode 5 Jack was has a working
vortex manipulator as he teleported a
lot ah dang it
oh good stupid thing stop moving
dang chat there's a pause feature on
this thing but I can never get it to
function reliably is probably the
dumbest question ever but in series 12
episode 5 Jack has a working vortex
manipulator as he teleported in to meet
Graham why did he steal the ship well
you still have to have somewhere to
teleport them to and I would imagine
Jack probably stole the ship because
he's Jack and how was Jack ever gonna
end up with a ship he's gonna steal it
that's just kind of how he rolls like
best-case scenario he'll win it in a bet
but odds are he'll steal it
where can we get it where can you get
what ah I don't know what the topic was
for that question
highly recommend ghostbusters the video
game warning Bill Murray phones in his
performance I've got so many games that
like I own but I haven't played and
would like to but like I said I don't
actually have more time on my hands so
you mentioned you didn't get the word
doctor even after listening to a box set
where he's on his own
why would you say that is um I'm not
actually gonna answer that because the
review of that box set goes up on Sunday
so stay tuned your natural lip color it
looks good on you honestly I'm not like
my pale sickly little lips hey you know
we all we've all got a different thing
going on do you watch bo2 that horsemen
no no because I do not want to be that
depressed
um are we in the purge prequel um I've
never actually seen the Virgin movies
like I know the premise was there a
plague as part of the build-up to the
purge because I feel like the virus is
the one that's per is doing the purge
I saw your video in Dead Poets Society
what other films do you think the same
about oh geez
well like I'll give you an example it's
a very different film but I'll tell you
a movie that I like because I saw it at
the exact right time in my life to see
it and if I'd seen it if I'd seen it
earlier I wouldn't have known what to
make of it and if I had seen it much
later I wouldn't have appreciated it
because it needs to be seen or I think
it plays best to young people young ish
and that's a Clockwork Orange I saw that
I was 1t I think yeah it was 20 when I
saw a Clockwork Orange which is kind of
the perfect age to see that movie app
but if I hadn't been ranked the
sweetspot first time I saw it I probably
wouldn't like it because I can look at
it and go there's a lot that's like um
I'm pretty sure if I saw it for the
first time now it wouldn't care for it
much but there you go
Jack stole his ship in the empty child
he's been a thief since day one yeah
them kind of my point but yes this
stupid bang is pissing me off the lip
shade I think and I think that Han Solo
is the Star Wars version of Jack yeah
probably the closest don't know if you
ever played Animal Crossing I know I
never have but it's a very gender fluid
friendly oh that's good it's not my kind
of game and those sorts of unwind II
relax do what you like games like that
and the sims there I
I need a goal I need something that I'm
working towards you know that's more tan
than just make your house prettier
collect some bugs I might know like give
me some I don't necessarily need
something to fight fight like give me a
puzzle to solve or something to hit oh
yeah I need more than that listening did
you believe ghin the other day and the
six doctors final speech gave me
goosebumps Jubilee really is a great
great story which I do think honestly is
a good entrance point for anybody
thinking
anyone who knows modern Doctor Who and
is thinking about trying Big Finish
Jubilees a honestly think might be the
best one possible to try as you first
have you ever seen the TV series life on
Mars um no I've it's it's been brought
up it's obviously he's got John sim in
it
people have asked me that one
sporadically he's one of those ones that
I've long said like I'm not against
watching but like it's a lack of time
it's one of those things that somebody's
probably gonna need to Commission me for
me to make it a priority and actually
get around to it I also kind of know the
twist I'm not gonna say it but I think I
heard you don't watch Rick and Morty why
because I gave it three episodes and at
that point I made the decision like I
can see why people like this it's very
intelligently written but I'm not in the
mood for anything this cynical and I
don't like spending time with any of
these people these are all terrible
people and that's not even like a fall
that's a feature that's part of how the
show's built well I don't want to spend
time with any of them so oh yeah Rose
Tyler or Clara Oswald Rose Tyler
look I Rose is not that high on my list
but I'll take her over Clara
I wouldn't say bow Jack is depressing
okay that's a lie
yeah see there you go um but it's a
weird kinda depressing like a happy
truthful escapism depressing yes that's
a narc that's as oxymoronic as it sounds
yeah um are you on ready technically
um I I have an account on reddit it's
under view or a while that's not under
counsel of geeks but I'm not on there
very much I can't remember if you
answered this but do you think a silent
Doctor Who episode could work um maybe I
don't know those kinds of gimmicky
episodes are really tough and doctor who
hasn't done gimmick episodes very well
most of the time so I mean like could it
yeah do I want them to try not really
although that said the fact that they
seem to have really gotten a much more
dynamic crew going behind the camera and
with the cinematography and everything
else and they were gonna try it that's
probably the best time but the sort of
way that the show is being shot right
now about to finish the deathly hallows
oddly a book read by Jim Dale the two
worst things about the series so far our
order the Phoenix and Lunas voice Wow
I don't know how Jim Dale does Lunas
voice order the Phoenix is tough that's
a hard one for me to get through and I'm
I'm right now I'm reading Goblet of Fire
to my kids so that means order Phoenix
is up next
hey how do you watch have heard of Daz
black no and no do you enjoy horror
games not especially um I don't like
being tense particularly I don't take a
lot of enjoyment out of that um yeah
horror films can work for me sometimes
but that's in a much more limited space
you know that's two hours in which I'll
be tense the idea of playing a horror
game and being tense
hour after hour after hour
you can bring from it but like for a
collective multi-hour experience of just
being tense that's that's not my idea of
a good time could you sell your lips
colorist Council of geeks brain colored
lipstick if I knew anything about
sourcing lip shades I I totally be up
for it you have a goal in Animal
Crossing is to get out of crippling debt
yes but the only way to get to do
anything is by acquiring more debt or
have I misheard that have you watched
either the besides I spend enough time
in my real life trying to get out of
crippling debt I'm playing that game
already have you watched either the
original or newest Twilight Zone series
I adore the original and honestly the
new one isn't bad I haven't seen any of
the new one I have seen some episodes of
the original and dang that that really
is a good show have you ever played an
escape room once as a team-building
exercise at my job that's the only time
I've done an escape room alright was
fine what is Big Finish Big Finish is a
company in the UK that produces audio
dramas and they have the Doctor Who
license so they have done a lot of audio
dramas with various doctors including
classic and some of the more recent ones
as well they they never get the current
doctor and they haven't gotten come
house you don't think they've gotten
Smith but they've gotten Tennant they've
had war doctor with John Hurt before he
passed they've had some that focus on
psychic characters they've had some
based around unit they've had some based
around they was Missy got a series there
was one around Derek Jacoby's War master
and there have been classic stories done
with Paul McGann's with the Eighth
Doctor Tom Baker the fourth doctor Peter
Davison the fifth Colin Baker the sixth
Colin Baker comes off great in audio
seventh doctor Sylvester McCoy they've
all had audio adventures and great
finishes they they do good stuff I
haven't loved absolutely
everything I've heard from them I made
the mistake of listening to
phantasmagoria
but they do good work do you think Big
Finish should do Red Dwarf audio from us
um yeah I think that team could work in
audio form sure
have you seen midsummer no I'm not lovin
monsters doesn't make me angry because
they still carried on doing dr. Olea
episodes I admire the fact they didn't
pander kept on trying and as such we got
blanket I mean like at this point I will
defend the initial kernel of a concept
of love and monsters but man the
execution is a disaster even knowing
what they're going for even being as
generous as I can with what it's trying
to say I still think it's a mess but
that's Ted like I don't hate it the way
I hate some episodes of it I don't hate
the way I hate the idiots Lantern I hate
that episode so much it's big finish
free where you can find it it is not
it's free no sir you can buy their
physical this don't have any and reach
they're all over there um or you can get
digital but you do have to pay for it so
that's part of why I recommend you
believe because you can't just go oh
it's pretty I'll listen to whatever it's
not like YouTube you got to pay to
listen so Jubilee isn't going to start
with because Big Finish audio adventures
aren't exactly cheap so when you get
especially your first one you want to
get one that's really good
see I don't really want you learn to be
14 but I think it will be so damn cool
if she
turned up for the 60th also more time
for the 8th in the special please yeah I
mean them I'd be more than happy see
calm again and that outfit again what is
your part of Vermont like uh Vermont II
I I don't know how to how to answer that
it's you you can't find a flat stretch
of land that goes on for more than maybe
a hundred yards before you're either
going uphill or downhill it's cold more
months in the year than it's warm but
when it's wet and when it is warm it can
be blazingly so it gets very humid and
the foliage is amazing I just sorted the
13th doctor funkopop was it worth
purchasing um I don't know I've never
actually bought a Funko pop the one two
three that I have were all gifts so I've
never actually bought one myself quick
name three roles that were played by
David Bradley William Hartnell the first
doctor and Argus Filch and salla and
Salazar and surd red wedding
what's-his-face you know who I mean I am
so far behind on these questions you
gotta watch the new Red Dwarf special
coming out I have at least one or two
series worth and I should probably catch
up one person although Red Dwarf
continuity isn't really me so I guess I
don't have to I don't know I hadn't
thought about it yet do you think there
will be a 60th anniversary special for
Doctor Who I'd like there to be I don't
know do you enjoy dark dark humor
um yes but big pulsating asterisks on
that because so many people I know use
the phrase dark humor basically just to
mean being cruel and claiming it's funny
and that's not dark humor that's being a
sadist so yes I do enjoy dark humor
however I don't enjoy a lot of the stuff
that claims to be a dark humor so so
like um Futurama has a lot of dark humor
Red Dwarf has a lot of dark humor
hey checkers Guide to the galaxy has a
lot of dark humor there's a lot of humor
made about death about existential dread
about the futility of existence but the
point is not to be mean to someone and
then go huh because they just nelson
months and that's not dark humor that's
being a jerk whatever you do don't
listen to neck ramadi a-- is the worst
bit of Doctor Who ever worse than hell
bent okay well now you actually have me
curious so and something tells me that
might have been your intent all along
Big Finish story I really wanted to get
to is the light at the end the
anniversary story but I'm hesitant to
pay full big finished prices that's
legitimate most of the Big Finish stuff
I've bought I've bought during sales so
I I feel you on that just sort of thirty
no that was the Funko pop gets that
question got asked again do you think
Peter Cushing is a canon doctor now I
because like isn't he firmly established
in those movies to actually be a human
being
um I still haven't seen those movies I
need to
that's on them whoa goodness that's on
the to-do list with a bunch of other
stuff the early Big Finish Doctor Who
stories are super cheap that's true um
but I think I do think you gotta be
careful of what ones you get so like I
actually the first one I'd listen to was
I think the first one they did sirens of
time which was pretty good but not
nearly indicative of how good they would
be later on Big Finish are making some
random stories free each week at the
moment was listening to war doctor one
oh yeah I saw that I did see that
innocence went up free
I reckon that a good idea would be for
them to actually stay that the master is
the timeless child that would add you
some motivation what do you think I mean
can't escape this friggin thing and this
concept of how do we fix it all right
look if then we're gonna do this idea at
all
making the master the timeless child
instead of the doctor would have made a
lot more sense so in terms of when they
did it that's what they should have done
instead of what they did but they didn't
do it so trying to do so claiming that
now will come across as nothing other
than them scrambling going Oh God people
didn't like it and look here's my
general thing with retcons something is
only worth retconning if the current
status quo actively makes it difficult
to tell stories anymore
so like retcon and Sherlock Holmes that
he didn't die in the final problem is
the only way you get more Sherlock
Holmes stories that's a necessary retcon
but I honestly do not feel it is worth
the time of the effort effort to wreak
on something that you actually don't
even have to acknowledge if Chibnall
or anybody if let's actually let's move
on from Jim know if whoever takes over
doesn't like the timeless child
I would much rather they ignore it and
never touch it never bring it up than to
build stories around trying to fix it
because that's the kind of continuity
circle-jerk that DC has been doing for
decades and it's it's not fun tell a
good story if something in the past
sucked ignore it you only have to wreck
on it
if leaving it as is cripples your
ability to tell future stories and the
timeless child honestly as much as I
hate it doesn't do that just ignore it
and you can see I'm prone to be worked
up a little bit that frustration was not
directed at the person who asked the
question just in general all right I
keep trying to keep up with the
questions but then there
Jumma no question just much love Thank
You Amanda I appreciate that these
things are zooming by me I got to stop
trying to keep up black humor and cringe
humor is not the same yes I agree but I
see a lot of cruel cringe humor that
people claim is black humor and it's not
did you watch the Elijah Wood Dirk
Gently series nope I never did get
around to that I wanted to i found
myself liking order the phoenix more as
i've gotten older particularly the stuff
with Umbridge in the school Stephen
fried it's a great umbrage by the way I
could believe that me when someone says
don't be sad be happy my goodness what
an idea why didn't I think of that I
know right would you want Cassandra to
return why that's ology my question for
the first time they brought her back why
actually being serious don't listen to
Nick Ramadi it's so not worth it
you'll be bored and cringing and very
outraged I mean bored it bored is the
worst thing you can say about any piece
of entertainment cuz I mean you can't be
energized with something making you
angry when something's boring it's just
like what's your most forgettable
episode of Doctor Who I don't remember I
just got my Big Finish out of audios on
audible said that five times fast
he's my monthly free credit to get one
do they have a lot of Big Finish
actually on audible I know there are
like Doctor Who books that are available
as audiobooks there but what would you
say is the worst movie you've ever seen
from any technical level probably robot
monster I don't think it's the worst
movie ever seen but I remember the first
movie I hated I'd add movies I didn't
liked before but the first movie I hated
was dead man which was the Jim Jarmusch
movie war master series one starts out
okay but then whoa you know that's for
me I'd like it didn't hook me at the
front either very well some will hate me
for this idea but Big Finish
subscription service you're far from the
first one to float it I mean the the
issue is that the reason their prices
are as high as they are is because
they're they actually run at a fairly
tight margin because you look at the at
some of the actress that they get and
they have to they have to schedule
around these people they have to
schedule everything else around their
availability they need to get these
people in and they need to go through
all this production and they do not even
the best-selling Big Finish story is not
gonna be heard by a fraction of the
people who watch any given
so to Doctor Who so yeah they they I'm
pretty sure that if they could afford to
sell the things for a little bit less
than they do they would but I so I think
I know it's been floated at them by
people I don't know if they've ever
seriously considered it but the I think
the issue would be I don't know if their
business model could sustain itself on a
subscription service will you ever take
a sponsor deal if yes what type of
sponsor I have been sponsored I've been
sponsored a few times I've been
sponsored by the radio versus the
Marsh's podcasts have been sponsored by
- Lane
I've been sponsored by Skillshare I've
been sponsored by cos daddy and this
this podcast is sponsored by Rage
shadow-like no as if actually funnily
enough they reached out to me the thing
is I actually do get sponsorship offers
that I turned down for various reasons
either because I feel suspicious about
the person reaching out to me a usual
early warning sign is there they're
claiming to be from some company or
other but they have an at gmail email
address they're reaching out to me from
but even some of the ones that are
legitimate I've like looked into what it
is they want me to promote and I'm like
I am NOT comfortable doing that
so I'm look I have standards but I am
for sale I am more than having to do
sponsorships assuming they're ones that
I'm comfortable with being honest I
think whoever the timeless child is just
takes away the characters agency and
that probably irritates me the most
um I think whether or not it takes away
characters agency in the grand scheme is
gonna depend on what they do with that
storyline I just hate it for how
important it make
the doctor so that's the thing the idea
of the timeless child in of itself
I don't hate I don't love either it's
the idea of the doctor being the
timeless child that I hate anything
could happen when the time of child due
to the redacted section from the matrix
you could easily explain that the pre
Hartnell doctors were a separate person
from the child I'm I mean look you can
but I don't want them to and again I'm
I'm coming back to the same thing I
don't want them to spend time fixing or
clarifying it I just want it ignored
like I know that there are things they
could do or that people have speculated
they could do or suggest it or whatever
like I don't care just don't ever talk
about it again that is my honest
recommendation it's not what will happen
but that's it that's that's it for me oh
stop asking about the timeless child I
can feel my blood pressure rising um
and know the worst phil member is
Birdemic i'm refused to watch Birdemic
we know the time timeless child's is
really the Rani
it's never the Rani battery going flat
fiber which means time for sleep nine
nine and thanks loves all the castle
well thank you for stopping in Amanda uh
let's say do you plan on getting the ACE
Doctor Who book at childhoods end I
would like to I don't really have the
time to read it so I don't currently
have plans the war master series one
starts out okay but then whoa you know
war master series I thought was
brilliant
okay hate me I think it'd be cool to
blink
bring Clara
you don't have to leave but go in the
corner and think about that
ah there are a couple on there for
example do you believe the holy terror
times at midnight but most of them are
just compilations of stories read by
individual people yeah that's what I
figured was mostly unaudible and those
sorts of things don't do as much for me
have you heard of all the roll swap hype
so basically Sacha Diwan being the
master and Jody with it there's Sasha
the one being the doctor Jody wood has
curved being the master no I hadn't
heard that what do you mean by hype like
people just hyped about the idea cuz I
can't imagine that they're actually
gonna do that what is your name my name
is Nathaniel or Vera depends on the day
in the context in which you are seeing
me uh uh there's a lot of older Big
Finish on Spotify an audible
I recently listened to the first tenth
doctor adventure on Hanukkah
oh my I feel like into that thank you
for turning down the great shadow legend
sponsorship you're welcome I do it for
you for like ah I like I said I'm not
above taking sponsorship but I don't
want to publish anything on you folks
that I think you wouldn't actually take
enjoyment out of or isn't worth your
time maybe a credits based subscription
service I don't know enough about how
you could possibly put that stuff
together to say yeah a fan fiction and
stuff like fan art nykänen haha I laugh
so hard at your reaction at the question
about Claire coming back you're such a
dad tis true tis most true Jackie Tyler
our nanny
um Breen I'm Jackie Tyler I suppose crab
now I have to go thanks for entertaining
me tonight well thanks for stopping in
I know that I I know I've been a little
bit on the grumpy side this evening oh
that's right Thank You Caroline I do
need to check the discord
the hairdresser's are going to be really
full when lockdown is over I have an
appointment already the question right
now is whether I'll need to push it out
further from where it currently is which
might have to happen I've already done
it once wait before I go it's Jackie
Chan's birthday oh cool okay so hang on
I gotta hop over the discord see what's
going on over there
and I'm starting to stare at my speech
so you know I'm having a good time
hearing you guys I just turned into
Shelly from South Park shut up turd okay
do you hear Clarks move for summertime
in the u.s. yes we have daylight savings
it's very very very very very stupid oh
no the racnoss oh yes I suppose that as
well
my children will feast upon you oh that
was not a live stream question whoops um
let's see Shh
that wasn't really a question sorry
sorry I'm quiet while I'm reading these
there was actually conversation that
happened in the discord so I'm just
trying to find if any of these are
actual questions that they wanted
answered on the chat
okay this is this isn't a question but
I'm going to read it anyways not a
question yet just to say that I think
your content is appreciated even more by
many at this time I'm separated from my
family and at home by work and lark
downs and thousands of miles oh thank
you very much I appreciate that classic
version companions you have seen snog
marry he avoid ooh um so I think it
would probably be snog ace marry Jamie
avoid Victoria you saw Clockwork Orange
and in college now class in high school
Wow I'm surprised they showed it to you
at that age what's your most loved
useless skill mine is that I can write
my surname with my left yeah with my
left in my last name with my right at
the same time um pretty sure what I do
on YouTube can be considered a useless
skill I don't know I didn't thought of
that is it too soon for Ezra Miller
jokes Oh Leigh dad
not that I'm much chaired I'm not a big
fan of Ezra Miller but God's sake right
it's my duty to put you off necromancia
permanently his handles adult subject
worse than early Torchwood II did oh god
I did predict avoid Victoria oh good
call
do you watch Brooklyn nine-nine yes but
I'm I'm very very far behind
have you watched The Magicians no sorry
and these times of hardship it is
important to remember the one and only
true rule of a functioning society it's
every man for himself
follow my Instagram Thank You Joel
you're lucky she's not looking what am I
not like wait a minute what was I not
looking at so I gather from tides
chattin recent video your ideal Doctor
Who episode would be the doctor has the
timeless child doing a Dead Poets
Society remake with Clara as his
companion oh I thought you'd pick a void
mouth she was in consideration I have a
conspiracy theory why is there no
question mark in Doctor Who it's a
question dear how goes your reading of
DC bombshells
I only did the first volume I don't have
any of the others at present it was
alright I had fun with it I think I'm
gonna appreciate Missy more during my
rewatch now that I know where they're
going with her arc I still hate the kiss
that happened to dark water though I
haven't seen that episode in a while so
I can't say I will say that in general I
I keep I keep seeing kisses that I've
forgotten about like the review won't be
up for a bit but I recently rewatched
the Crimson horror hi and I forgot that
kiss Jenny the grand is she smacks him
for which I appreciate it but like still
why do you know about the Doctor Who
audio rip offs made after it stopped for
the first time starts Sylvester McCoy as
the professor and ace I didn't but it
doesn't surprise me at all what if the
absorber love was the timeless child see
now you just try to bait me when I know
that's what you're trying to do I can
brush it off I have a conversational
opinion i ii don't like series six okay
do you like groomers replacement and
season seven of Red Dwarf I feel like
I'm drawing a blank there I don't
remember Rimmer ever being replaced
Adric is winking at you but Egon is
kicking him basically it has TNA Oh aah
I'll go back in the corner yeah yeah do
that Colin Baker also made videos as the
stranger huh I do the casting a Barry
Allen and a standalone flash film now
Ezra Mellon might be out of the picture
unknown ideally so nobody I could name
have you ever seen the cabinet of dr.
Caligari I have not I can't speak for
whether or not Ezra's in incident
represents him as a person but I'd be
really surprised if he's still the flash
at this point I mean the thing is the
flash movie has been coming together a
falling apart and coming together I'm
falling apart over and over and over and
over again for so long and they and DC
seems prepared to completely just drop
that continuity anyway so like I don't
think they'd have any reason to keep
them work to keep them around I don't
think that necessarily means they're
gonna replace the flash they might just
say heck with it
and work with other characters for a
while what's your favorite first Cape
character
Harvey if you could meet one deceased
doctor actor Hartnell trout and pertwee
herd which would it be ooh if I'm
meeting the actor as opposed to the
character probably pertly I had this
opinion but do you think in chickens
arrow the doctors been domesticated
doctors always against domestic really
it's not just me that thinks this I
don't know why you'd consider this
doctor to be any more domesticated than
any other doctor I would actually argue
that 12 was pretty domesticated for a
chunk of time there is it bad my
ultimate aim is to see someone
cosplaying one of the characters from my
short films no not unless you consider
it bad that one of my ultimate aims is
for the book that I'm working on to be
popular enough to generate fan art and a
fan wiki so I feel yeah uh this is my
apology thank you
by the way if you ever want to see a car
crash of a show
check out the various American version
red dwarf pilots I already have I've
seen him or I've seen I've seen one of
them I guess they did more than one I've
only seen the one but boy boy I sent you
a video on his room about the Doctor Who
knock-offs
alright cool check that out at some
point do you feel the new coming is like
a sense of relationship with the doctor
um yeah as we've gotten through series
12 and she became a bit more prickly I
have to wonder if part of that was
intended that having a more crowded
TARDIS was a way to delay the revelation
that she's actually not connecting
with these people as much as the doctor
normally connects with companions and
that it takes you longer to notice that
may have honestly been the plan but I
don't it may have worked to that effect
but I think the ultimate result is as
audience members we don't really know
this doctor very well because so much of
how we know the doctor is through their
relationship with the companions and the
thirteenth it doesn't really have nearly
a strong one snog marry avoid Rimmer
Lister the cat snog the cat marry list
or a void Rimmer would you want Jody to
stay for another series after 13
personally I would because she's an
amazing doctor and is bubbly in her
darker moments that's why she's my
favorite doctor I mean I don't know I
think that's Nona largely depend on what
I think of series 13 to be honest I'm
not expecting her to because at this
point I just kind of assumed three
series is gonna be standards but we'll
see what Batman Joker mix and match
would you like to see if any example
Adam West's Batman against Heath
Ledger's Joker oh um um that is ooh I
actually don't know because under the
best circumstances the Batman is always
well tailored to the Joker he has um I
suppose I just had the stupidest idea
Ben Affleck's Batman taking on the
arkham verse joker but specifically the
arc averse Joker from the very end of
Arkham Asylum so the roided-up Titan
formula Joker good because that feels
like it would fit with the Snyder
version
all of that ah would you cosplay
cross-race for example latest master
even though technically not human I
would not no no I I'm not gonna make any
statements about whether or not anyone
else can or should I will say never
darken your skin just don't do that
the feelings about whether or not it is
okay to cross play as a character of
another race even if you're not
darkening your skin is one that there's
a lot of different opinions on and is
what I don't feel equipped to weigh in
on what I'll say is that for my own
personal comfort I would not be
comfortable cosplaying as anyone who was
very clearly not of a similar ethnic
heritage to myself but that's just
that's me and personal comfort that's
not even like oh you shouldn't like I
wouldn't cuz I would feel really weird
and awkward doing that do you think the
thirteenth doctors too human like the
tenth hey you don't think so that
doesn't automatically mean that all
ultimately like her better than intended
but I don't think so I'd be the greatest
Batman Joker fight ever that'd be
hilarious thank you I'm kind of oddly
proud of that do you think thirteen will
go down the whole time Lord victorious
route because she's the timeless child
and kind of a god-like figure I honestly
don't know I suppose it's possible it
really does depend on what Chibnall
decides he wants to do with this
storyline now that it's out in the open
[Music]
all right I am gonna wrap it up soon and
drink the rest of this in peace so that
I can slur my words away from the rest
of you ace Rimmer what a guy
haha casually sips wine well yes
should always do so casually unless
you're in a hurry which case chug chug
chug chug have you read any of the
companions of doctor books I have not
persistent coughing of the Daleks a
second class Oh usually the end of the
class means the end of stream though the
stream is still gonna end just guess I
wanted to put out in the world like I'm
not done drinking today but I love you
committing to your water intake I do you
think that Jim Nell actually has a
five-year plan from the gearshift from
series 11 to 12
I'm gonna guess no um what storyline if
we ignore it it will disappear very good
you're learning have a good evening I
have to go all right I am gonna wrap up
but I want to answer Ben's questions so
here's the thing I actually do believe
him that he has a five-year plan the
question becomes how much he sticks to
it I think honestly I think it was
probably a problem with his overall
approach that he had a five-year plan
and as opposed to a 3-year plan what I
mean by that is I'm looking at the
progression of just the doctor as a
character from series 11 to series 12
and I can see how these are like steps 1
and steps to to something that's going
to happen later
but if he's do
this towards the geared towards
something that's not gonna happen for
another three series after this I think
that was a mistake I think he should
have narrowed down and come up if you
wanted a plan and have a three year plan
so that it's a clearer trajectory and
it's less likely to go off the rails in
the process take it sleazy thank you
because the problem the problem was
plant the further out that you plan the
more room there is for things to go off
the rails
the tighter the plan the more you'll
just get to execute what it is you're
planning the longer it stretches out the
more things that you can't control can
throw you off because there are some
things that we will probably never know
whether or not it was always planned for
Ryan and Graham to leave at the point
that they're leaving was that always the
plan or did Bradley Walsh say I can't
keep doing this schedule and that wasn't
part of the plan who knows if it wasn't
part of the plan that means things have
to change and they have to shift you
know if Jodie Whittaker decides to leave
after series 13 was that always part of
the plan if it's not how does that
affect the plan our plans being adjusted
based off audience response you know I
think there's this this idealization of
this concept of a long-term plan and I
think we get hung up on that because we
remember lost which was a show that
didn't have a plan but everyone thought
they did and then by the end you rise oh
you guys were just making it up as you
went along and then we see a handful of
very well executed things that clearly
had plans in place like first four
seasons of Game of Thrones or Breaking
Bad and things like that were clearly a
plan was in place and was followed but
it's really really really tough to take
a plan and stick with it and the longer
term it is the harder it's gonna be to
nail down and keep
on track because things will change that
you can't help so Jeff Jones recently
said he has a three season plan which
makes me think he's trimmed down to
getting out of the show earlier due to
the backlash but that speculation well
what he says three season plans that
three season from what he started or
three season from like now because if he
has a three season playing like it right
now that is three plus the two he
already did so that's five again so
question is when he said that anything
non TV can be ignored yeah canon with
doctor who is anything that isn't the TV
show is basically optional for example
they never planned all ten years of the
MCU from day one exactly and that look
those benefits and there's hazards to
doing it either way
so I already talked about the hazards of
having a long term plan which is that
can you adjust the plan as you go
because that was actually the same thing
that went wrong with the DCE you and
with Zack and with Justice League and
everything that was supposed to happen
after they went in to bat they came out
of Batman V Superman and we're leading
up to the premiere of that film with a
plan they had a plan for Justice League
Suicide Squad was already there they had
a plan and then Batman V Superman did
not make the money they expect it and it
definitely didn't get the reception they
wanted and suddenly back to scramble and
try and change something that's already
thundering out a track they're trying to
tear up the track while the Train is
still in motion so that's how badly you
can go wrong when you have a plan when
you don't have a plan you can sometimes
end up with something like lost but for
the most part I actually think it works
better to not have a plan past one maybe
two seasons so let's say don't have any
ideas for after that but an active plan
keep it to that because then once you
finish your initial plan ago great what
can we do next
because that's a big part of how the MCU
was constructed they didn't have a
master plan they made it up as they went
but they also built something malleable
enough that they could make the
adjustments they needed to as it was
going with the reason lost failed so
hard is not because they made it up as
they went along it's because they made
it up as they went along but it was a
show built around a mystery it was built
around the entire height the entire
Phantom was built around don't you want
to know the answers but there weren't it
so the reason the fact that they made
that up as it went along failed so hard
was because the entire premise and
appeal of the show depended on there
being a plan but there wasn't one so as
long as you don't do that I actually
think for the most part it's smarter to
not have a locked-in plan and that's not
to say locked in plans never worked
Breaking Bad worked very well but even
that they still made adjustments they
still made alterations to the original
plan but that still did basically go the
way that they wanted it to you're very
angry at the timeless child trying to
hide something
council geeks is the timeless child oh
god they're on to me Gotham and the
Russell T Davies era and Doctor Who are
the best example of not having a plan
see here's the thing I not only do I
agree I would actually argue the reason
season 5 of Gotham is so bad is because
they did have a plan but they had a plan
for a full season and they only got 13
episodes and they tried to execute it
anyways and it was junk it didn't help
that the showrunners played up that
there was us that there was a
scientifically reasonable plan yeah yeah
pretty much do you even have a plan
do I look like someone who has a plan
even the wire screwed the pooch in
season five I seen the wire I hope
nothing is done with the universe the
timeless child came from oh yeah I keep
forgetting that that's a thing that they
could theoretically dip into oh that
would reestablish the divergent arc that
wasn't even that good when Big Finish
did it I don't even know but I'll trust
you
Kawara and me are the timeless children
Batman Returns or Batman Forever Batman
Forever it's more fun I have a plan for
series compiled of a load of random
ideas that he needs to turn into whole
episodes that actually sounds like how I
started this channel improv is as
important skill as planning divergent
sorry not divergent I was wondering if
that was a typo do you think chim know
would bring back Susan or Jenni I have
no idea
TNG didn't have a plan and had a better
ending than lost
don't say you hope something will happen
it'll just tempt fate you know that what
if Chris Chibnall cast himself as the
doctor that would just be weird with
everyone asking for TV show
recommendations
I'll keep plugging gala vane yes yes
pirates please do ah
if you have Netflix you can watch
galavant it's two seasons it's awesome
season one is fun season two is great
and I am I don't know when but I am
gotta make a video highlighting camera
and why he is freaking awesome ah if I
were John Lee blacksmith what a happy
guy I'd be oh whatever I scream you try
to make it always turns into a Doctor
Who Q&A I know that was why the last Q&A
he was very explicitly not Doctor Who
questions uh I will forever recommend
Merlin I get that one right now
I love King Richard Wright Oh Richards
the best I'm going to make my once per
stream plug for the expanse think you'll
love it I appreciate that you keep
plugging at that do you think Susan knew
the doctor had lives before I have no
idea I know everybody I want to kill my
brother drinks are on me
uh Richard was the best
she'll be mine's my favorite song from
galavant Oh favorite song see there's a
weird one I actually think the recap
song that the Jester does towards the
end of season two is my favorite because
it's it's the song from the very start
of the show on steroids it's super fast
going through all everything that had
gone on that season up to that point
oh it's good and I can sing that one and
it's am i right most of the gestures
stuff is in my range actually galavant
out of my range Sid's out of my range
Richard is in my range the Jester is in
my range so I get to sing down and
that's that is ah that's a lot of fun I
will always recommend the thick of it
Malcolm Tucker is my spirit animal uh
unfortunately I can't quote him I'll get
the I'll get the archived version of
this demonetized
this live stream is sponsored by Rafe
dark myths use code geeks to get 0% off
your first purchase late joke but you
never noticed it
I don't mind I'm drinking which would be
better us doctor or British Star Trek
I feel like British Star Trek already
happened it was called Blake 7 ah but
why do you wear your hair to that side
because this is the natural part of my
hair and this is the way my hair wants
to go if I try and do it the other way
it it can work but like my hair fights
it it doesn't it doesn't like you're
going that way so like that's that's
just my natural part so that's why it is
the way that it is I liked how Eccleston
would casually avoid complicated
questions I'm bad at processing sci-fi
explanations the other ways go 80s hmm
okay so penny wise and the Cybermen get
into a fight who wins I mean probably
penny wise if there's only one Cyberman
oh very here the other um well I think
this is because it pooped up more on put
it the other way which classic who
campaign you would fit best with a
thirteenth doctor oh I don't know it
actually won't be the case but I'm gonna
say Jamie cuz I love Jamie cuz Jamie's
the best ever noticed how zombie Lane is
just American Shaun of the Dead I hadn't
thought that but yeah basically is I I
was gonna wrap up I'm still here what
the heck
recently my favorite childhood book
series started again the protagonist
came out as bisexual has more blatant
LGBTQ plus representation I'm very proud
of skulduggery pleasant
that's very cool uh-huh the absorb off
gets into a fight with quicksand who
wins you don't mess with a quick exam
can we just have a galavant sing-along
stream she asked hopefully here's the
thing about that I would honestly be
happy to do it the problem is I'm pretty
sure the stream would get shut down like
remember when I tried to read from from
a doctor who decide your destiny book
and the live stream got shut down
because because the bots detected that I
was reading copyrighted work I'm pretty
sure the same things gonna happen if I
sing more than a couple of bars of any
given song so for me to do any kind of a
sing-along stream it couldn't be on
YouTube it would have to be somewhere
else and I don't know where would be or
how that would work
but I was about to suggest 13 and Jamie
that'd be hysterical
I could imagine Jamie thinking the
doctor has been transformed into a woman
since he never really learned about
regeneration uh yeah that would throw
him off uh twitch I don't know don't you
need to be gaming to do twitch when's
the next back time string eat my cakey
your arms out of my head I mean I didn't
say that really I'd do it for you I
suppose you could play you play connect
the dots it's a race against a river and
Jack who kisses the doctor first Oh see
that's tricky because they both fight
dirty
not anymore there's all kinds of stuff
on Twitch these days I hate trying to
learn other platforms uh elbow how
risque yes I know hey Caroline what's up
did I miss something
no harm' just think of the children
haha dream on inside I suppose what is a
twitch everyone soon boy what uh what a
glorious disaster that would be imagine
13 and 12 meeting comedy gold comedy
gold
I'm telling you it's comedy gold
hey Larry no you're good just a few
thoughts running through my head Oh
wheels spinning thoughts on how River
always says her phrases the same way it
quite annoys me
it's its catchphrases I'm okay with that
wrap up this live stream already given
that you spelled rap without a W I'm not
entirely sure what you're encouraging me
to do there as an American has the right
to bear
before dr. and Graham would be comedy
gold oh that that would be something
what is on your isolation binge list
American Gods at the moment thanks for
your video and positive masculine eight
you're welcome
I've been actually really really happy
with how that turned out
I'm glad that people liked it as much as
they did excuse me uh Donna puss river
post Captain Jack Post doctor for equals
objectively quality and also not
kid-friendly oh goodness
give me a break as to of am here my eyes
are hurting I'm not making you stay up
you're choosing to who here wants the
tux to be 13 in costume that tux did
work pretty well
have you considered making a favorite
characters in fiction list for the video
I've made one that had the doctor the
master and captain Holt on it um no I
hadn't figured that just because I'm not
sure I could wrap my head around a
subject that broad I I need to narrow
down do you watch the crown no my mother
watches the crown I never got into it I
can't wait for the episode that takes
place at the Pizza Express okay thoughts
on the passing of honor Blackman oh yeah
that that was a bummer um so in case
folks don't know that name actress honor
Blackman who is best known for playing
don't demonetized me for saying this
YouTube for God's sake [ __ ] Galore in
in Goldfinger passed away I was a bit of
a shame Benji the first ten seasons of
The Simpsons acted I'm not I didn't have
a stroke that's how it's spelled Benji
next are all for Toy Story movies in a
row ha ha ha
nice may I say you are quite lovely in a
crisis I hope you get the reference oh I
feel like I did but like it's not
coalescing properly in my head I know I
recognize that all about those sexy
hands ooh
fresh nail color got that going for me
so it's not it's not chipped hey
actually do I enjoy just doing stuff
with fingers I'm identifying myself
especially when I have nail polish on
just enjoying the movement of fingers
left the live stream to watch galavant
saw the first five seconds and I love it
cool yeah no I'm definitely got it
I'm one of the things I'm trying to do
and it was kind of a general goal anyway
but definitely go this summer what brand
polish do you use home all over the
place I can't even remember what well
I've got on my fingers right now because
actually two different colleges and a
topcoat and I'm pretty sure from three
different brands um but what was I gonna
say oh so I think I'm trying to do is I
am trying to do some things that really
geared towards stuff that I love and I
don't just mean like why it's awesome
videos I mean things like that are
really more proper deep dives into
things I'm working on editing something
right now that'll be for May that I'm
really enjoying doing
I have plans to do a couple more I'm
gonna try and squeeze in a couple more
fan videos for the breakroom related to
shira but I want to get up before the
new season starts so I want to try and
get a entrapped a fan video up and
possibly one more after that depending
on how long it takes me because finding
fun is really
important right now I've cracked it
Benny is the timeless child yeah
rewatched midnight I study psychology so
it reminds me of stuff like the Stanford
Prison Experiment oh yeah or Milgram
studies that have environments and
stimuli that made people that makes
people amoral yep
dr. companion mashups - and Amy three
and Donna Oh that'd be interesting
foreign graham seven and Sarah Jane okay
nine and Tegan okay that I could see
twelve minutes yes yes twelve anis
forever oh my god yes Xena Warrior
Princess is also being run as a marathon
just saying okay I do need to wrap up
and drink the rest of this I hope
everybody is staying safe staying sane I
thought that's the thing that I think we
need to add to that stay safe at this
point might start being the easy part
and now it's um
now stay save and stay sane it's the
combo that's the tricky part but um I
hope everybody has a good night and I
wish the best for all of you so just
remember you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved you are the counsel
I'm just round the meetings have a good
night